- We've released a
report that shows
the FTC's doing
what they're doing,
naming journalists by name,
asking what interaction
the company's having with them.
The next day, two
of them testified.
Democrats asked them
who their sources are,
and while they're testifying,
one of those journalists,
the IRS is showing
up at their door.
That happened, literally
again, in a 48 hour timeframe,
and yet the Democrats say oh,
there's no weaponization
of government.
Are you kidding me?
(mysterious music)
- All right, day three
of three here in DC,
and joining me today
is U.S. Congressman
representing Ohio's fourth
district, Jim Jordan,
and the Congressman representing
Florida's 19th
district, Byron Donalds.
Guys, welcome back.
- Good to be with you.
- So first off,
I've got to ask you
about the sleeve situation.
We've got a nice suit here,
your sleeves were not rolled
up, you just started rolling.
I thought that was
your trademark,
they're always rolled.
- Well, I guess
sometimes they're rolled
up, sometimes not.
But it's good to be with you.
And Byron's always looking good,
whether he's got a
jacket on or not.
- Listen, this is
the calm Jim Jordan.
Give him time, give him time.
When it's time to
get into the issue,
it's just gonna happen.
- I'll start asking
you about IRS overreach
and we'll see it.
- No kidding, that's scary man.
- All right, we'll get
into that in a second,
but I thought it was
interesting what we were
just talking about a second ago,
you mentioned how Ohio
and south Florida,
southwest Florida,
there's a connection there
because of the
snowbirds and all that.
Does that leave you guys
in an odd competition
to keep people in
your own district?
- No.
- They all like Byron's better.
- They just come to my district.
There's no competition.
- It probably is a little
bit of a tougher sell
for the Ohioans,
right, going to.
- Well, literally some
of our best supporters,
guys who have been with
me for a long time,
spend a lot of their
time in Byron's district.
We were just out in
Naples, had breakfast
with a couple of them
a week ago Sunday.
So yeah, it's a great part
of the country as you know,
because you've got
family down there.
- Yeah, yeah.
All right, so let's get
into some of the issues.
So yesterday there
was this hearing
basically about
government overreach.
What was the actual
title of the hearing?
Government abuse, something?
- Yeah, we didn't have
it in our committee,
but it was probably in
the Oversight Committee.
I mean, there's all kinds
of government overreach.
We're actually watching from
the basic premise, Dave,
that we think so many
of these agencies
have been turned
on the very people,
the American people that
they're supposed to serve.
And you can see it
time and time again.
And just remember what
happened three weeks ago.
Three weeks ago, Chuck
Schumer goes to the floor
of the United States Senate
and tells Rupert Murdoch
don't let Fox, telling
a major network,
don't let Fox play
the January 6th tapes.
The very next day,
we release a report
which shows the FTC is
targeting a private company,
asking that private company
who are the journalists
you're talking, Twitter,
you're talking to?
Names four journalists
personally.
The following day, two
of those four journalists
testify in front
of our committee,
and while they're testifying,
the Democrats ask them
who are your sources?
That all happens in 48 hours.
- Yeah, that was incredible.
I mean, when you watch
some of this stuff,
and you're somewhat new here,
when you watch
some of this stuff,
and you have Democrats
literally trying to get sources
out of journalists,
not knowing the basics
about technology and phones
and how these tech
companies operate.
Is it mind blowing to
you that these people
are even asking some
of the questions?
- It is, but wait, I've
got to segue for a moment.
Notice the sleeves are now up.
- Oh, the sleeves are up.
- The sleeves came up,
so notice that happened.
Okay now, back to business.
It is mind boggling.
Sometimes it's just
flat out insane.
And what you start to realize is
the Democrats are always
looking to fill their narrative.
The facts don't matter,
the issue does not matter.
It's what's gonna
fill the narrative.
These are the same
people who were basically
trying to be the
defenders of the media,
but now when a story doesn't
come out in their favor,
they want sources,
they want the press
to get rid of their own
journalistic integrity.
None of that matters.
The only thing that
matters is either
perpetuating the narrative or
protecting their narrative.
And that's one of the
saddest things that we see
up here on Capitol Hill.
- When Schumer made
that statement, we
played it on my show,
and I said he basically
made a mafia tactic.
That's what he did, because
he basically said to Rupert,
hey, that's a very nice Fox
News you've got over there.
It would be a shame if
that thing burned down.
And then the pressure's
on, and they basically hope
you will destroy
your own business.
- Well, we see that
time and time again.
When big government was
pressuring big tech,
they were threatening the
230 issue and other things.
Either do what we want,
take down these tweets,
we think these tweets
violate your terms.
I mean, think about that.
The government's telling
Twitter, we think these tweets,
we think these violate
your terms of service.
When did the government
get in that business?
And to finish that
narrative, think about it.
So Schumer says it.
We released a report that shows
the FTC's doing
what they're doing,
naming journalists by name,
asking what interaction
the company's having with them.
The next day, two
of them testified.
Democrats ask them
who their sources are,
and while they're testifying,
one of those journalists,
the IRS is showing
up at their door.
That happened literally,
again, in a 48 hour timeframe,
and yet the Democrats say oh,
there's no weaponization
of government.
Are you kidding me?
- So that was Matt
Taibbi yesterday,
as you were questioning him,
IRS shows up at his door.
I take it this stuff
doesn't surprise anyone
here at this point.
Like is that shocking?
- No, that actually
doesn't surprise anybody.
And so that's when we
started taking a closer look
at all the different agencies
and having a real scalpel.
When there are people
saying, do you know what,
maybe we should
reform these agencies
and maybe we need
to cut work force,
the reason is because there
are really good people
in the agencies who
are doing the work
that they were hired to do,
and then you have these
subgroups that exist,
where their entire
purpose is to play gotcha
with the weight of the
federal government.
Or to suppress or to
dissuade or to diminish
thought process,
idea, et cetera.
Look, even with COVID, we saw
it with the COVID narratives.
CDC going to media companies,
CDC going to social
media companies?
There are documents.
- Buying all the commercials.
- Marty Makary,
Jay Bhattacharya,
these guys have
far more experience
and technical knowledge than
some of the folks at the CDC,
and they were suppressed.
We have the documentation,
it's all on record,
and it was coming from
elements of our government.
Here's what I would say
to the Democrats now.
If you truly believe in
protecting the soul of America,
if you truly believe
in saving democracy,
you can't allow elements
of our government
to suppress speech of
the American people.
It cannot be allowed.
- How does the
response go on that?
- They want to
protect the narrative.
The response is, what
are you talking about?
That's not true.
Or that was misinformation.
We can't let misinformation out.
But who's gonna be the arbiter?
Who's gonna be the judge?
AOC, Rashida Tlaib, Maxine
Waters, Nancy Pelosi?
Nah.
- For the record,
we tried to get
every single one
of them in here.
We got only one response,
and it was a no.
That was from Rashida, so
I'll give her at least half,
I'll give her half
credit for responding,
but nobody else even responded.
You've been fighting
these fights forever.
My sense yesterday, having
sat with Speaker McCarthy
at the Capitol, is
that Republicans are
starting to wake up,
even just the tone that
you guys have right now.
Like there really does feel like
something might be turning here.
Are you hopeful for that?
- I am, and it's interesting,
because Taibbi wrote a piece
over the weekend where he
thinks that is happening
in a broader sense too,
not just Republicans.
I do think Republicans
get now, look,
we've seen so many
of these agencies
turned on the American people.
And the fundamental
issue I do think
is what Byron and you
were just talking about,
is this attack on
the First Amendment.
I mean, I always tell folks,
one of my good friends,
Dennis Kucinich,
old school liberal,
who truly believes in the
First Amendment, he does.
- He's a far righter now, right?
(laughter)
By their standards, yeah.
- But literally a friend,
because he still embraces
the First Amendment like
the left used to embrace.
But today's left, as Byron was
just describing, they don't.
It's like they use it to
go after their opponents.
We don't care about
the First Amendment.
And every Democrat,
this is a scary thing,
almost every Democrat
is an operative.
You know, Republicans,
they're running their family,
they're volunteering at
church, and their school,
and doing little
league and all that.
But it seems like every
Democrat's an operative,
including many of
these Democrats who
are in these agencies.
So I do think this is
the fundamental issue
because if you don't
have a First Amendment,
think about it, your right
to practice your faith,
your right to petition
your government,
your right to assemble, freedom
of press, freedom of speech,
the most important
one is speech.
If you can't talk, you
can't share your faith,
you can't practice your faith,
you can't petition
your member of Congress
to redress your grievances.
Speech is the most important,
and that's the one
they're coming after.
That's why we have to defend it.
- So speaking of speech,
you've had a couple
of nice moments in
mainstream media lately.
You had a blowout, or
you could describe it
in our own words, with Joy Reid,
and it was pretty
indicative of, I think,
everything going on here
with the mainstream media
where they're
acting as, you know,
I think she considers
herself a journalist, right?
I mean, if you asked
her, she'd probably say
she's a journalist.
But she clearly is an activist.
Do you think she was not
prepared for that moment?
I mean, we clipped
the entire thing
and showed it on the show.
You just calmly,
clearly debunked her
in real time live on MSNBC.
- Well no, actually I
thought she did come in.
She wanted to come in hot, she
wanted to come in rapid fire,
you know, try to have
me stumble or side step
or have to re-state something,
and that's the clip.
So kind of going in,
that was my mindset.
It's like okay, they're
gonna try to do something.
Just be prepared, be calm,
and then just take
it step by step.
I think going on her show or
some of these other shows,
what I think it helps
my colleagues understand
is you can go into
the lion's den
and do ideological warfare,
or warfare might be too much.
But you can have that dialogue,
you can have that back and forth
and actually come
out the other side.
I've had a lot of people
come to me afterwards,
they were like, man, Joy didn't
look good in that interview.
And I don't even say it like,
I don't even put it out there
like look how I owned her.
People say it, I just watch.
- Right, right, right.
- But at the core of it
is you have to be factual.
So a lot of my guys on
our side of the aisle,
I tell them, guys, just
be solutions-focused.
Just be focused
on the solutions.
They're gonna bring the
energy and the fire to it,
and you can go back
to that with some,
but if you always have
in mind the end goal
is the solutions,
the constitution,
like Jim was talking,
the basic freedoms,
freedom of speech,
First Amendment rights.
If you do that, you
can win that argument
because the biggest thing
we're having to deal with
right now is that you
have conservatives,
we are the ones
trying to, frankly,
save the soul of America.
We're the ones trying
to save everybody's
constitutional
rights and liberties.
It's not the left, and when
you go into their shows,
into their wheelhouse,
and you talk about
that stuff, it shows.
You have more people in the
middle of the road in politics
who basically like,
why is Joy Reid lying?
Social security is
going insolvent.
It's in nine years, nine.
- This parental education
bill that passed, thankfully,
I was watching AOC afterwards,
and she's talking about how
this is fascism basically,
and simply all it was was
that parents will just know
what the kids are being taught.
Can one of you please
go to AOC's office
and explain to her
what fascism is?
It's driving people crazy.
- Well, but there's
also this button,
remember what Terry MacAuliffe
said a year and a half ago
in the gubernatorial
race in Virginia.
He said we don't think
parents should be telling
government what their
kids get in school.
- And you've gotta
thank him for that
because it basically
turned the election.
- Yeah, but it's
like you step back,
just think about
that for a second.
Okay, so some
bureaucrat in Richmond
who doesn't even
know the kid's name
cares more about that
child than a mom or dad?
Like it's just so stupid,
it's so ridiculous.
And the good people of Virginia
saw it for what it was.
And that's sort
of the basic here,
is we actually believe that
moms and dads know what's best.
After all, they know their
kid's name for goodness sake.
Some bureaucrat in DC doesn't.
So that is.
- Well, the teachers
are literally
trying to re-name the kids,
that's part of this nonsense.
- So it's so basic.
I actually have said
this in interviews.
I tell them don't
vote for anyone
who's not for school choice.
You've got Republicans,
pick the Republicans
for school choice.
That is so fundamental.
That's the only way in the
end we ultimately solve it,
and I wish we could have got
more of that in the bill,
but it's a good bill that
embraces this fundamental idea
that moms and dads care more,
know more about what's best
for their son or daughter.
- Well, speaking of that,
we did this week in Florida.
- We did it again.
- Again.
- I mean, look, I'm happy
for the people of Florida.
It's something that's
been a long time coming.
My former speaker,
Richard Corcoran,
back in the Florida legislature,
actually stopped me from filing
that bill, not in a bad way.
Richard understood because
the Supreme Court at the time,
before Ron DeSantis
became governor,
as a liberal Supreme Court,
and he was like, Byron,
if you file that bill,
we're gonna pass it,
and if you pass it,
the Supreme Court's
gonna strike it down, because
they're waiting for us
to strike it down.
So I want to make sure I
set the record straight
for Richard and his
conservative bonafides.
But this has been a process,
a journey for Florida
for quite some time,
and I'm just glad
that my colleagues back in
Florida, and the governor,
they just said we're
doing it, and let's go.
Because at the end of the day,
you want to have a system
of education where,
like Jim said, the
parents are first in line.
If I get to choose where
my kids play basketball,
where my kids go
to after school,
who's the actual
doctor for my child,
what clothes do you wear,
what shows do you watch,
although, you know,
today it's much harder
for parents to do that, if I
get to choose all those things,
I don't get to
choose the school?
That is disrespectful of
the position a parent has
in their child's life.
Florida recognizes that, I know
Arizona recognizes that now,
I think you said it was Utah,
and there's gonna be more.
- Arkansas is doing right
now, Iowa's doing it, yeah.
- That's right, and more
states are gonna follow.
- Do you think
fundamentally the issue
for the Democrats on
this is they realize now
if they lose the schools,
I mean, that's how they won
this thing for
the last 40 years.
So they sort of feel like oh,
if we can't start these kids
on that path when they're
literally five years old,
we'll be in trouble.
- Yeah, it's that coupled with
just public employee unions
and the power based in the
Democrat party for a long time.
So I think it's those two
things meshed together
is why you see them so
against school choice,
so against empowering
moms and dads
to make decisions
for their kids.
And this crazy line about,
we had a hearing last week
that I thought we went well,
where we were talking about
the parents issue and what
the DOJ and things had done.
But the Democrats
were talking about
Republicans want to ban books.
And like, there's a big
difference between book banning
and age-appropriate literature.
And that is the
fundamental issue.
And for them to argue,
it's just so stupid.
We're not for banning.
You're the ones who
want to restrict speech.
We're for like, but
there's a difference
between what a second
grader should be able to see
and what a 12th grader and
what someone in college
should be able to see.
Like that's common freaking
sense, for goodness sake.
- I mean, the whole
thing is so stupid.
I'm sure you saw it,
when Governor DeSantis
was giving the press
conference about it
and he took out two of the books
which were clearly
pornographic in nature,
and the news had to cut the
feed because it can't show porn,
basically, in the
middle of the day,
and that's the stuff
that they want there.
- Yeah, look, I was there,
I was on ground zero.
We pushed that bill
through the legislature
when Rick Scott was governor,
and we pushed that through.
And at the time, the
Democrats in the State Senate,
in the State Legislature,
were losing their minds.
You can't do this, you
can't have taxpayers
and parents look at material.
They don't have the
expertise to do this.
And our entire statement was
if taxpayers are paying for it
and the children of these
parents have to look at it,
shouldn't they be
able to just comment?
Do that with your
local school board.
Engage in civil discourse in
an actual democratic process
with your local school board.
That's a good thing.
And it's really good to
see this now has taken fire
throughout the country.
Unfortunately, a lot of kids
had to be subjected to material
that they should not
have been subjected to,
but look, if there was one
silver lining of COVID,
it's that parents
got a chance to see
what's actually going
on in these classrooms
and in these schools,
and that's actually
to the betterment
of our country.
- Are you guys doing any
version of this in Ohio now?
- We've had good school choice
in Ohio for a long time,
and our Senate president,
great guy, good friend of mine,
is the most pro school
choice guy you can have,
so they are expanding
school choice there.
But I think there's
a broader thing
that also came through with
COVID and with this debate,
is I am so sick, and this
is the left's position now,
the experts make the decisions.
That's not how it works in
our constitutional system.
It's the people who put
their name on a ballot
and get elected, they make
the decisions because then,
if you don't like it, you can
throw them out in two years,
and that is a darn good thing.
Instead, it's the Faucis
and the Collins of the world
who make all the decisions,
and Dr. Fauci never once
put his name on a ballot,
went out and shook hands,
talked to the people, and
got elected to anything.
But frankly he ran the
country, ran our lives
for three stinking years.
And everything he
tells us, by the way.
- He also lied under oath,
which you guys alluded to.
- Yes, everything he told
us turned out to be a lie.
- Yeah, are you feeling
pretty good I assume,
that when you come down, or
come up here from Florida,
that everyone on your side
is going, man, Florida.
Like you feel it.
Everywhere I've walked
around out here,
everyone's like,
Florida man, Florida,
Florida blueprint, Florida.
- I mean, what can I say?
(all laughing)
You know, we're the leader
in the nation right now.
Look, honestly
the Florida story,
and I say it a lot in a
lot of different rooms.
We're like obviously the
hot thing going today
for obvious reasons,
great leadership,
great governor, all that stuff.
This has been a trajectory,
this has been a pathway
for 30 years in our state.
I think probably the last time
we talked I talked about it.
What you're seeing
now is what happens
when you have
consistent conservative
governance in an area.
You see the opposite
in California.
People are leaving in
droves, crime is rampant,
drugs are rampant, it's crazy.
Their legislature has
gone off the rails.
And so what happens?
Businesses flee, capital
flees, families are fleeing,
kids aren't learning,
they're being stuck
between a rock and a hard place
because the teachers' union
is striking because
the custodial union
wants more money.
That's what's happening
in California.
Not Florida.
So if the rest of the
country wants to be
a place where people want
to go to start businesses,
buy homes, live their dreams
and do everything else,
Florida is the blueprint.
And frankly, up here
on Capitol Hill,
Capitol Hill needs to start
taking cues from Florida
so that the entire nation
can thrive this way.
- Yeah, and that is the whole
point of a blueprint, right?
I mean, that really is it.
All right, let's just knock out
a couple of the other things
that you guys are working on.
This TikTok ban, I don't
know if you saw this thread
with some of the real specifics
of what is in this bill.
This thing seems
pretty dangerous to
me, the bill actually,
in terms of it's basically
Patriot Act for your phone now.
How concerned are
you about that?
- I haven't looked
at the details yet.
I know Senator Hawley may
make a motion sometime today
or tomorrow, and we're all
concerned about the China part
and what's going on here.
But I do get concerned
that when you're trying
to do something good, which
is what would happen here,
it winds up restricting liberty.
And knowing where the left has
been over the last few years,
what they're doing with
the cancel culture mob
and everything else,
that does concern me.
- Yeah, have you checked
into what's going on
with this bill?
I mean, I know the
idea of basically
of going after
China spying on us,
that's one thing, but now
it seems like it's a bill
basically designed for
every bit of our data
to be used against us.
- Well, I've got real concerns.
We're still going
through this stuff,
but I've got concerns initially.
When you talk about
TikTok specifically,
let's be very clear.
The Chinese government is
taking a digital picture
of the decision making process
of young people in America,
and people who use
that app in America.
That is exactly
what they're doing.
It's the same model
that all social media
is largely built off of, that
depending on what you look at,
you kind of see what's
good and what's not,
and you can filter and do
all that kind of stuff.
I don't trust the Chinese
government at all.
So that's my issues with TikTok.
What we shouldn't do
is essentially re-do
the Patriot Act
on a larger scale.
The Patriot Act, by the way,
I get the premise obviously,
9/11, but what we've
done as a result
has not been good
for the country.
- Yeah, I mean it basically
led to all of this,
and now they're trying
to do it on our phones.
Let's talk about the financial
stuff for just a moment,
the bank bailouts
and everything else.
Do you put all the blame on this
on just that Biden has, in
essence, caused crazy inflation
and these banks are doing
a bunch of risky things
and this was the
obvious outcome?
- Well, I think that was
sort of the main thing,
is the record inflation,
which impacted the treasuries
of what they had in these banks,
and they weren't liquid
enough to meet the demand
from certain depositors.
I think that's obvious.
But it's all the spending
that drove the inflation.
I mean, it's like
literally record spending,
and of course his budget,
the President's budget,
we were at record
levels of spending,
and he increased it even more
with his proposed budget.
So we've got to get
a handle on that.
And frankly, I think
we've got to get in place,
and I've pushed for this,
the idea that when we get
to the end of the fiscal year,
we can't have this
shutdown scenario.
So what I want is a no
shutdown act so that, okay,
we want to spend less,
they want to spend more.
The Democrats always, when
they have the White House,
oh, Republicans want to
shut down the government.
I want to say no, no, we won't
shut down the government,
but we'll spend at some
current level minus something,
and then you can
have a real debate.
Because if we don't, we'll
get into the crazy stuff.
So that's what I want
on the debt ceiling,
that structural change.
We'll see if we can get that.
- Do you ever think
maybe a shutdown
wouldn't be the worst thing?
I mean, they always frame
it as this is gonna be
the worst thing ever, but
I'm kind of coming around
to the idea of, okay, let then
shut down for a week or so.
Let's see how badly.
- Well, we've done
that several times.
- No, I know.
- Politically, you're
right, it doesn't hurt us.
- But I think in some
ways now, it's almost like
I think the fear is
oh, if we shut down,
people are gonna be like,
oh, we don't need these guys.
Like I think something has
actually turned psychologically.
- I think so.
I mean, look, I remember
even back the beginning
of this Congress, and we're
having all that stuff going on.
And it all worked out, it's
actually been a very good thing.
The media was
losing their minds.
Oh my gosh, Congress
hasn't convened.
And day two, what's
gonna happen sir?
And I'm like, kids are
gonna go to school.
- I'm still able to get eggs.
- People are driving on
the street right now.
The country will still function.
We'll figure this
out and move on.
I think even if you
get into the topic
of government shutdown,
the reality is
people still go to Disney,
even though Disney's doing
some silly things.
People go to the beach.
- You could have said Sea World.
- I mean, but what's
the limit, September?
Trust me, the NFL's
gonna be playing games.
Like life will continue.
Washington's gotta get
its house in order.
And this is the part
that is critical.
We have to get out of
this, to Jim's point,
this brinkmanship
shutdown mentality where,
as a new guy on the Hill,
it is mind boggling to me
why we don't have guys
sitting in conference rooms
all over the Hill going
through spreadsheets right now
saying, okay, what about that?
Well, this is that thing.
We can't really spend like that.
We've got to cut this here.
We have all the time in
the world to do this,
except one thing, there is
no political will to do it.
Because if you have
to sit down at a table
and go through budgets across
from your political opponents,
that's all well and good,
you can actually get
to a deal pretty quickly.
- Is that particularly
weird for you
because we're in a
state, Florida, where
we have a surplus,
we don't have a state income
tax, but everything's working,
infrastructure projects,
20 year projects,
the governor told me,
are now seven years
because we have to build faster
because so many
people are coming.
Like it's working there.
Then you come here, and you're
like, guys, can we do math?
Does anyone know how
to carry the one?
- But also in most
state legislatures,
you have a mandatory budget.
That's constitutional.
You have to pass a budget.
It has to balance.
You don't get to deficit
spend in the states.
Here, meh, oh, we're short
a couple of hundred billion?
Oh, okay, throw it
on the credit card.
You can't do that
at the state level.
States have to
balance their budgets,
which is why in a lot of
respects, people want to get
balanced budget amendments
up here in Washington.
I totally understand that.
But at the end of the day,
it's the people you send.
If you send members up
here to Capitol Hill
who are not serious
about the physical future
of the country, you're
gonna see more of this,
and that's the stuff
that we want to stop.
- When you're talking
to Democrats about this,
is it that they
fundamentally just believe
you actually can
print money forever?
- Yeah, almost every
Democrat does, yeah.
They believe that
modern monetary policy,
you're on the Fed, I'm not on
the Federal Service Committee,
but that's what they
believe, and it's frightening
because, I mean, we're
seeing what happens now.
The inflation is just, 41 year,
42 year high inflation rate.
- Let me ask you guys one more,
which obviously
there's some momentum
with the Republicans
right now, clearly.
This Trump-DeSantis thing
seems like it's heating up.
You knew I was gonna have
to ask one way or another.
You had a great answer
for me last time on it.
You know, I keep telling
people I feel like
I'm gonna win either way
because either DeSantis
remains my governor,
which will be just fine,
or potentially he's president,
which would be great.
Or if Trump's
president, that's great,
and I've still got DeSantis.
You know, like short of
Biden being president again,
there's a win in it, I
think, for Floridians.
But you guys might end up
on slightly opposite sides
of that thing because
you're obviously a Trump guy
in that regard, and I know
you like President Trump,
of course, but you're
a Floridian also.
How do you deal with that
internally when it gets hot?
- Well, I mean, I'm
for President Trump.
I've said this many times.
I don't think we've
ever had a president
who did more what
he said he would do.
I may have shared this
story with you before, Dave,
but Mark Meadows and I
are in the White House,
probably, I don't
know, 2017, 2018,
and we're in the West Wing
there, in one of the rooms,
I think it might have been
Jared or someone's room.
Big white board.
Literally they had
every promise written
that President Trump made
to the American people
in 2016, every one.
Cut taxes, reduce regulations,
embassy in Jerusalem,
build the wall, all of them.
And they were just
checking them off.
And I think that's how
you're supposed to govern.
So I'm 100% for President
Trump, and I want him to win
because I think he's got
the toughness to do it.
I like Governor DeSantis.
When we formed the Freedom
Caucus, there were nine of us.
He was one of the original
nine, so he's a good man,
done a good job in
Florida, but I'm for Trump.
- You want me to answer now?
No, I mean look, at
the end of the day,
the back and forth is gonna
happen, it's politics.
I've been through tough races,
Jim's been through tough races.
You don't come up
here to Capitol Hill
without going through them.
You definitely
aren't going to get
to the highest office in the
land without going through it.
It's gonna be tough, it's gonna
be bare knuckles at times.
That's just what it is.
So I think for people in
the conservative base,
you've got to understand,
we've seen this before,
we've done this dance before.
This will get worked out too.
Look, if Donald Trump is
president, phenomenal.
If Ron DeSantis is
president, great.
The thing we've got to do
is we've got to
clean house in DC.
DC's gotta get a house cleaning.
And the one thing I know
about President Trump,
he's committed to that work.
That work will begin.
- Gentlemen.
- Thank you, brother.
- You've got work
to do, I assume.
- That's right, that's right.
- Get out of here.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.